sure enough it's a rematch of the week
16 Saturday night or though is on NFL
Network it is a wild-card game in the
house of the AFC North champion
Baltimore Ravens and the guy who did
pick off Baker Mayfield to make it all
cemented CJ Mosely here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you CJ how about you
what makes his defense go CJ he's person
collectively from the players to the
coaches you know we all trust each other
when we all on one Accord and playing
fashion over a deadly defense and what's
your role in it I'm just good to call
out if you get the call out there you
can play ball that's not the main thing
so it goes into your helmet and then to
everybody else is what you're saying
yeah okay now that fourth down play I'm
sitting there at home watching it and
the rest of it prior to that Tony Romo
was on CBS saying that he was expecting
the house to be brought every single
time because that did not happen in
Kansas City and the Ravens were not
gonna let that happen again was that
dough the thinking that was going on at
the top oh yeah you know that's one of
our you know go to calls when we got to
have it no long bring the house and now
let our TVs don't do their job and play
great coverage and I'll just I'll just
so happen to know pop out at the right
time and make the play and at the time
when when you did that well what were
you thinking as you were running up the
field and blowing kisses to the crowd
this was sour relief I suppose all it
was and three years in a row you know
you had to make it you have to make hard
on what it was once again far as a
defense and I just finally cat out to
the last play again we got it done so I
got probably back in the Big Dance were
you thinking that it could be a repeat
of last year with Dalton that's well
coming off the foul on when we punted
that's exactly how I said but you know
the whole the whole shoes drives the
whole jobs was like just do our job and
taking one play at a time and you know
we have some I know we're absolutely
yeah - big big pass breakups no I rush
did a great job but make him throw the
ball fast you know they did a good job
- big place - with all repairman and
Landrus that I made two big catches but
no we just stay resilient and before I I
move on from from this game in
particular how good is Baker Mayfield CJ
I gonna be great
no he's been good he's definitely gonna
be great um this is pull his poise
throughout the game and throughout this
whole season oh the dear rookie
quarterback and you know they have that
organization I pretty much put that city
on his back and I made them made them
believe that they can be great so he
doesn't have gonna be causing problems
in NFL for a long time is he talking out
there um i far as far as I know I didn't
real estate so much - um no all nobody
really says his defensive line and they
they see him more than I do
okay all right CJ Mosley here on the
Rich Eisen show now you've got a rookie
running a quarterback yourself CJ and
you know in the decade-plus that I've
done this gig with the NFL Network and
obviously this show there were so many
times when veterans certainly when they
have a great defense in the making when
when a coach turns to a rookie
quarterback in the middle of a campaign
there's a lot of eye rolling or
potentially concern that everything that
the hard-fought aspect on your side of
the ball could all go down the tubes
because somebody green is under center
what was it like when Lamar Jackson got
the gig CJ um it was exciting
just from as far as a defense standpoint
of what we saw where we saw him do when
he's not on scout team against us no we
saw the abilities we saw the passes you
can make it clear that we know what type
of runner he is but I won't be first I
gonna get his first start reading the
auditors didn't know what to say I
didn't really know how the officers was
gonna change up and we kind of kind of
starting a Clemson Glenn stuff and more
each week and I think at this time now
you know the whole play below for him
know he's making great reads and the
pass game definitely making a great
reason to run games
weathers him running the ball to handing
off to our you know I'm running back so
I'm just a new it's a new breath of
fresh air energy for the team so how'd
ya who's gonna ask you that CJ how do
you feed off of it
the smashmouth aspect of the offense how
does the defense feed off of that
oh we love it you know it just like what
a defense
stopping around on an opponent and and
when I offers out there and you know
they know we know that we're going to
run a bar and control the car and when
they do it and make a statement and also
keeps us off the field so we can make
our adjustments try to you know get our
office back on the field so it all plays
it all plays a part when it we're not
doing a great job controlling the clock
and keep on keeping the lead and keeping
us off the field so when we do get back
on we'll be ready to go so what it's a
challenge facing you having already
faced an opponent with Philip Rivers
potentially a Hall of Fame quarterback
in many people's minds coming into your
house just a couple weeks after you
actually went into theirs and won that
game what's the challenge here um keep
the same mentality the same enthusiasm
that we had we went out there you know
the past the past seven weeks you know
Vivaan we've been mentally preparing
ourselves to play playoff football every
week because that's what we needed to
get to the playoffs you know and now
that we made it all we gotta have that
starting focus and just turn it up
another notch you know that's that's
what we pretty much just impression City
Agra guys and other guys that haven't
been in a playoff that you know it's
just do I take it one play at a time
vacations not any other day we're gonna
play off every play matters
CJ Mosley here on the Rich Eisen show
tell me your favorite tea sizzle story
what's your favorite Suggs story a lot
of those you know I was always remember
when I when I first first got drafted
here and I'm sorry here for OTAs and all
that so you know the guys the I practice
you know playing music in there but his
relatives like choir you know a couple
guys hard to hear in there so if I re
wait till agencies get here you know you
definitely gonna know and you know the
first day he came from an account yeah I
can't tell you what he was saying but it
was a lot of there's a most third thing
was saying I well yeah this you can
definitely tell when TC is in the house
no but please he's a great guy great
leader of course the future Hall of
family man I'm I told him I told him
yesterday I was I was happy that I was
able to win the north with him so
hopefully we get a Super Bowl - I'm Ray
Lewis reached out to you what's your
relationship with him CJ I haven't
talked to him recently but our
relationship is well you know I actually
actually met him my last year Alabama so
the summer time became stammer talk to
the team that's when I first met them
there's you know the next thing you know
I
about him the Nexus a nice tombola
usually what we talk you know this is
we've had to talk about football and
assembly and all that but um no I have
his number so he always turning over
anything I knew I could reach out to him
but he's a great guy so I mean if you
got a guy like that your side it's a
logical our I mean that's pretty big
shoes to fill CJ I mean usually guys
struggle in that regard when they go to
a new you know a new press new level and
then have to step in for somebody like
that guy how did you deal with that well
the best way to deal with it it's not
compare yourself to someone like there
and they just add in more pressure to
yourself
it was our no pressure no going to run
to the Ravens and you know Venice then
one another linebackers been a first
round face to me there's no point to try
to compare myself to the greatest
linebacker in a field that's just not
just you know wasting your time he's got
it do what do what you've done to get
you a that to that spot and I felt for
the most part I've done that and I'm I
know I'm not like great little is
obviously with the motivation of
speaking and all of that but now one of
the guys always so if I if I do my job
on the field you know it has to be
loudly more loudly to what I say off
CJ Moseley a four-time Pro Bowler in
five seasons the NFL that's one way
that's one way to start filling shoes
right here on the Rich Eisen show tell
me the story in which Nick Saban once
showed you the toughest love what's the
toughest love Nick Saban story from you
CJ Mosley I would say my freshman year
so we was playing a Duke and I think
losing man coach and I had I had to run
a back wheel and so I like I blew my
coverage and went to go try to get a
second I got a first down so when I got
off the field you know he gave me a co
savings screaming and talking yelling
but the way I might hit off my alright
I'm a freshman so he probably not gonna
say too much but one thing I just said
that stuck with me sort of the day is
like no matter how old you are with your
freshman or sinner I'm a coach like
you've been here so I really stuck with
me today cuz I assumed since I was
younger I didn't have no potential or
and my job was an airport and so after
that play I kind of looked at I looked
at what I did
on the field and off the field fire
studying and being prepared on
differently so I'm just wondering for a
Crimson Tide player would you rather get
aired out right away or have your name
written down on that note Carter his
calmly yeah that's a new one I haven't
seen him do that yep until this last
game right yeah it's usually usually
usually just see it also on his face in
soon as you get on the sidelines he just
unleashes around buddy maybe that's
maybe that's gonna keep keeps him calm
he does he knows this is right a couple
notes down to know to keep their keep
the pressure up again yeah cuz I prefer
I'd prefer to know it right away just
gets get it out of the way instead of
just like okay let's revisit let's put a
pin in that and revisit for later I
don't think I'd I don't think I'd really
want that so how do you see yet another
match up with Clemson working on Monday
CJ I think with our offense nose is just
so dynamic you know since I've been in
South Alabama and you know years prior
with Coach Saban we never had an office
second I can just score at any point at
any time you know we do have some great
players and great great teams but as far
as our offerings it goes whether I
defense late the best game in their life
you know maybe have a couple mishaps in
there I often score or I'll score
anybody an arm in a you know in the
league so that's that's one thing that
we have for so I mean whether it's a
shootout or a low-scoring game I office
has a chance to win it do you know if
Lamar Jackson voted for tool over Cuyler
do you know who he voted for in this
house I'd asked them I said hey
hopefully it wasn't thought to you and
went and when we're married since we
since we beat them earlier in the year
that's right I'm just trying now now I'm
putting all the pieces together hey CJ
thanks for the time really appreciate it
last one for you before you go you're
hearing all the conversation about your
head coach potentially still not being
around there there's a lot of chatter
involving John Harbaugh his future how
is the team addressed all that CJ um
well right I think right after he got
back from the bar you know I had our
team you know he pretty much nipped it
in the bud no he said he wasn't going
anywhere here to stay and I don't know
they know when
the top the top leader of your team you
know stands up and say we're not going
anywhere
all we got to do is win no we took that
in chard and pretty much won the rest of
the way you know stuff was on the one
loss but after another day you know
since things are gonna get said that
that doesn't pertain to the inside our
locker room inside our building so I was
gonna do is focus on what we have to do
and what we can control and I'm usually
when you win and stuff pays off and
that's what we got to keep doing so John
Harbaugh stood in front of you and the
team in the by or after the bye and
flat-out addressed it with all young
guys yeah I pretty much said no don't do
not worry about that I'm leavin we're
going you know we focus on football we
focus on winning and that's pretty much
bid then I've been our vision and our
goal is just to win win and take it one
week at a time CJ good luck this weekend
I appreciate the call let's chat again
soon yeah thank you you bet that's CJ
Moseley Ravens linebacker at traduce 32
RTR on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience